[Musique]
c'est dans les hauts de Sainte-Suzanne
plus précisément un Bagatelle que série
Melchior président du Département
accompagné de Maurice Gironcel maire de
Sainte-Suzanne à inaugurer la maison
d'assistante maternelle MAM les babies
en fait le département participe à la
réalisation de ces membres le but c'est
quoi c'est de regrouper sur un même site
plusieurs travailleurs des assistantes
familiales qui se maternelle pardon qui
se regroupe de façon à mutualiser leurs
moyens et le département porte une
investissement mais aussi en
fonctionnement et on le voit bien quand
on voit une belle structure comme ici à
Bagatelle que cela répond un vrai besoin
cela répond à un vrai besoin parce que
dans les quartiers parfois on peut
considérer comme étant éloigné des
centres-villes et bien il y a des
parents qui travaillent qui ne trouvent
pas moyen donc à garder leur les enfants
à la maison et donc c'est même répondre
à cette attente si tu es chemin ringué
cette structure
par 2 sort assistante maternelle conduit
place ce qui porte à 40 le nombre de
places offertes sur la commune
[Musique]
m² avec une grande pièce à vivre un coin
jeux pour les bébés un coin repas un
grand jardin d'enfants devant et à deux
chambres pour les bébés nourrissons et
un pour les plus grands à partir de 2
ans il y a des petits couchettes après
il y a une salle d'eau avec
douche avec plein de gens pour les
enfants
la Réunion compte 1754 assistante
maternelles donc 200 à s'être lancé dans
l'aventure de la maison d'assistante
maternelle ce qui représente sur
l'ensemble du territoire aujourd'hui 67
MAM pour une capacité d'accueil de 823
places c'est une offre complémentaire
nous avons
trois crèches communales nous avons
également eu deux crèches privées plus
également des micro-crèches et nous
avons aujourd'hui également c'est la
troisième map qu'on est bien que
troisième
donc ayant encore beaucoup d'enfants qui
attendent par ici s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]